dire à madame la rapporteure générale
s'agissant de la taxe et sur les
organismes complémentaires que vous me
connaissez suffisamment pour savoir que
la question s'est posée et que de fait
sur environ 2 peu plus de 2 milliards
d'euros 2 2 nom dépenses on en a pris il
ya 2 2 milliards d'euros d'économies en
a pris 1,5 milliard les années
précédentes donc la question se pose est
légitimement le choix qui a été fait a
été de ne pas prélever de taxe
complémentaire
mais de demander avec fermeté à
l'ensemble des organismes
complémentaires de modérer les contrats
en tout cas de modérer les cotisations
et la hausse des cotisations pour
l'année 2022
je dois vous dire madame la rapporteure
générale que pour l'instant je ne
dispose pas de chiffres par définition
nous sommes nés en 2021 mais que les
premières prises de position de certains
acteurs du monde des complémentaires
annonçant que la hausse des contrats
sera au moins égale à celle de
l'inflation me laisse présager que le
message n'aurait peut-être pas été
suffisamment clair ou peut-être pas
suffisamment audible auquel cas compter
sur la mobilisation de toutes mes
capacités de conviction pour rappeler
les engagements que nous avons demandé
en échange de cette modération sur les
taxes que nous aurions été des victimes
a prévu
[Musique]